Now that we have a little bit
of a review of oxidation and
reduction under our belts, let's
see if we can apply what
we now, maybe, re-understand
to cellular respiration.
So cellular respiration, for
every mole of a glucose,
C6H12O6, we combine that--
and maybe that's
in an aqueous state.
It's dissolved in water.
We combine that with six moles
of molecular oxygen.
And then our cells perform
cellular respiration in a
whole series of steps.
And I'll do more
videos on that.
I'll just abbreviate it.
And then we end up with six
moles of carbon dioxide.
We have to breathe this oxygen
in order to perform cellular
respiration and we have to
breathe this carbon dioxide
out because it's just a
byproduct of cellular
respiration.
Six moles of carbon dioxide,
six moles of water.
And the whole point of cellular
respiration is, plus
some energy is generated
by this reaction.
And our bodies store
this energy.
Well, some of it is just
turned into heat.
But the whole point of cellular
respiration is to
store it as 38 ATPs, which we've
learned already is the
energy currency of biological
systems.
And then our bodies, or
biological systems in general,
can use these ATPs to contract
muscles or generate nerve
impulses or grow cells or divide
cells or whatever else
that a biological system
has to do.
In the last video we learned a
little bit about oxidation and
reduction, so let's apply
those ideas here.
Now we saw in the last video
that a chemist would say-- let
me write it this way-- a
chemist would say that
oxidation means losing
electrons, or not being able
to hog them.
While a chemist will
tell you that
reduction is gaining electrons.
And if you have trouble
remembering, oxidation is
losing, that's kind of OIL,
that's the mnemonic.
Oxygen is losing electrons.
Reduction is gaining.
Or, RIG.
So OIL RIG.
This is what you learned
in chemistry class.
Now biologists or biochemists
will say, oh, well, you know I
like to define it a little
bit differently.
A biologist will say that
oxidation is losing hydrogen
atoms. And they'll say reduction
is gaining hydrogen
atoms. And we saw in the last
video that this definition is
actually hard when you're
applying it to hydrogen
because it's not like a hydrogen
atom can lose itself
or gain itself.
And the reason why we said
that these two ideas are
consistent is because if I'm
talking about a carbon and a
carbon is losing a hydrogen.
So let's say I have some
compound that looks like this.
Maybe it's connected to a
bunch of other things
someplace else.
And then later on the carbon--
let's say I have a carbon that
looks like that and I have an
oxygen that's maybe bound to
another oxygen.
I'm doing a very kind of
hand-wavy explanation here.
And maybe that oxygen is bonded
to something else.
This is what I start off with.
And on the other side of this
equation I end up with
something that looks
like this.
Where a carbon is bonded
to an oxygen.
And maybe that other oxygen is
bonded to this hydrogen.
The biologist will say, oh, this
carbon has been oxidized
because it lost its hydrogen.
The hydrogen went from here--
I'll do it in a different
color-- went from this carbon
to this oxygen.
And the biologist would
also say that this
oxygen has been reduced.
It's been reduced because
it gained hydrogens.
But the reality, or maybe the
chemists' definition, which I
like a little bit more is, over
here because carbon is
more electronegative, we
see carbon is much more
electronegative than hydrogen.
And oxygen is even more
electronegative than carbon.
When any of these guys bond with
hydrogen they're going to
hog the electron.
So here, carbon got to
So here, carbon hogs
electrons.
While here, carbon gets its
electrons hogged by oxygen.
So here, oxygen hogs.
So by losing the hydrogen, the
carbon actually lost its
opportunity to hog electrons.
And since it ended up bonding
with an oxygen, it not only
can't hog hydrogen's electrons
but then it gets its electrons
hogged by an even more
electronegative atom.
So that's why these two
definitions are consistent.
Same thing with the oxygen.
Here it's bonding with another
oxygen, not hogging anything.
But when it gains the hydrogen
it's able to
hog hydrogen's electrons.
Because it's so much more
electronegative.
Or you could say that it's
gaining electrons.
So that's why these two
definitions are somewhat
consistent.
Although sometimes they fall
apart if we're not dealing
with hydrogen.
The chemistry definition applies
more consistently to
everything.
But sometimes the biologists'
definition is easier to kind
of glance at.
Or you'll actually see it
written in textbooks.
So let's go back to cellular
respiration and try to figure
out what's being oxidized
and reduced.
So if we look over here.
Over here we have our glucose.
And actually I copied and
pasted from Wikipedia a
glucose molecule.
And actually there's
one error here.
And maybe I should edit
it on Wikipedia.
There should be another hydrogen
bonded to that carbon
right there.
But as you see, all of the
hydrogens, they're either
bonded to an oxygen or
a carbon over here.
On the left-hand side, they're
either bonded to
an oxygen or a carbon.
If we were to write its
oxidation state, in every case
it's bonded to something that's
more electronegative.
So it's going to be giving
up its electrons.
So it will have a plus
one oxidation state.
And oxygen, in every case,
is either bonded to
a carbon or a hydrogen.
And so, oxygen, if it's bonded
to a carbon or a hydrogen, is
going to hog an electron from
either one of those guys.
So in every situation in
glucose, oxygen has a two
minus or a minus two
oxidation state.
And carbon, since this whole
thing is neutral, one would
think that carbon would have
a neutral oxidation state.
And if you go through this, you
actually find that most of
these carbons do have neutral
oxidation states.
Let me circle a few.
So for example, this carbon
right here, it's hogging an
electron from this hydrogen.
But then it gets an electron
hogged by this oxygen.
And then of course it does
nothing with the carbon.
So that's neutral.
This is neutral for
the same reason.
This one is also neutral
for the same reason.
It's bonded with two carbons.
It has an electron
hogged by oxygen.
But then it hogs an electron
from hydrogen.
So it's neutral.
So four of these carbons
are neutral.
This carbon right here has two
electrons hogged by oxygens.
And then it gets to take one
back from the hydrogen.
So it has a plus one
oxidation state.
This one is the opposite.
It has two hydrogens
that it hogs from.
Then it has to give one
away to the oxygen.
So this has a minus one.
So these two cancel out.
On average, you can say that the
carbons in glucose have a
neutral oxidation state.
And I'm dealing with the
chemist definition.
And I'm going to show you
that they're essentially
equivalent.
Here all of the oxygens have
no oxidation state.
Because they're just bonded.
Let me do it in a
better color.
No oxidation state or neutral
oxidation state because
they're double bonded
with oxygen.
No one's hogging from anyone.
They're obviously equally
electronegative.
If we look at the
products, carbon
dioxide looks like this.
So, in either of these cases,
oxygen is hogging two
electrons from this carbon.
So it has a minus two
oxygen state.
This oxygen is hogging two
electrons from carbon.
So it has a minus two
oxidation state.
And this carbon is getting all
of its valence electrons, all
four, hogged by the oxygen.
So it has a plus four
oxidation state.
It's lost four electrons,
you can imagine.
Because it's getting hogged.
So that's carbon.
So we could write this as four
plus for the carbon.
And then each oxygen
has a two minus.
And we can do the math later
on to figure out
what the total is.
And then, if we look at the
water-- we've looked at this
before-- the oxygen is hogging
two electrons,
one from each hydrogen.
So two minus.
And then each of the hydrogens
have a plus
one oxidation state.
So if you want to do a half
reaction for cellular
respiration, and in the
chemists' sense of things,
just dealing with electrons,
you can immediately say, I
start with 12 hydrogens
on this side.
Let me just write it this way.
So H12 on this side.
They all have a plus one
oxidation state.
And then cellular respiration
occurs.
And now I have 12 hydrogens.
I could write the 12 a little
bit differently here.
But they still have
a plus one.
Each of them still has a plus
one oxidation state.
So nothing from an oxidation
reduction point of view
happens to the hydrogen.
Now if we do the carbon.
On the left-hand side of the
equation, we have six carbons.
They have a neutral
oxidation state.
But then on the right-hand
side of the
equation, what happens?
I now have six carbons.
Written a little bit
differently.
But I have six carbons.
And they each have a plus
four oxidation state.
Which means that they have
lost four electrons.
Or their hypothetical charge,
by losing those four
electrons, has gone
up by four.
Because they're losing
negatively charged electrons.
So the six carbons, after
cellular respiration, end up
with six oxidized carbons,
with plus
four oxidation states.
Plus-- so each of these
lost four electrons.
We have six of them.
4 times 6 is 24 electrons.
These are the electrons that the
carbon lost. So we see in
cellular respiration that
the carbon is oxidized.
Oxidation is losing electrons.
We see in cellular respiration,
we draw the half
reaction, carbon is losing, the
six carbons are losing a
collective 24 electrons.
And then finally, if I were to
do the oxygen on this side.
I've lost my equation up here.
So over here I have
two oxygens.
And I'm going to draw them
a little bit separate.
So I have these six oxygens
here that have a minus two
oxidation state.
On the left-hand side.
So I'll draw it like this.
They have a minus two
oxidation state.
And then I have these
12 oxygens that
are completely neutral.
So I won't even write an
oxidation state or oxidation
number there.
And then after we
perform cellular
respiration, what happens?
Well now I have, in the carbon
dioxide, I have 12 carbons
that have a minus two
oxidation state.
Six times O2.
So let me write that down
from the carbon dioxide.
So I have six O2s that
all have a to
minus oxidation state.
And then I have another six
oxygens that have a minus two
oxidation state.
So plus six oxygens that have
a minus two oxidation state.
So if you think about it, over
here I had a collective
oxidation state on all
of the oxygens.
These were neutral.
I have 6 times minus 2,
that's a minus 12.
You can kind of view it
as collective charge
of all six of them.
6 times minus 2.
Here I have 6 times minus
2, which is minus 12.
And then I have 6 times 2
oxygens per molecule.
So that's 12 times minus 2.
That's minus 24.
So to go from a minus 12 to a
total oxidation or kind of
hypothetical charge of
minus 36, I must
have gained 24 electrons.
And those 24 electrons that
I gained, that the oxygens
gained, are the same 24
electrons that the carbons
lost. So from the chemistry
point of
view, it's very clear.
Carbon was oxidized.
And oxygen, which gained
electrons-- RIG.
Reduction is gaining.
Oxygen is reduced.
And this is all a
bit of review.
But it's nice to see it in
the context of cellular
respiration.
And this actually kind of
answers one of the questions
of where does this
energy come from?
In any of these chemical
reactions, when you see energy
being produced, it's because
electrons are going from a
higher energy state to
a lower energy state.
If I have an electron that's up
here in a high energy state
and it is able to go to a more
comfortable state, lower
orbital or lower
energy orbital.
So low energy or more
stable energy state.
It'll generate energy in the
form of heat, or maybe this
can do some work in some way,
help make ATP molecules.
And so when you see these half
reactions, you see these 24
electrons, that are being
lost by carbon,
carbon is being oxidized.
And they're going to oxygen.
They're going in a whole
series of steps.
It's not just happening
in one huge explosion.
It's happening over a huge
series of steps.
And as it does that, it's
entering lower and lower
energy states.
And as these electrons enter
the lower energy states,
essentially by going from the
carbons and being pushed to
the oxygens, that's where the
energy is coming from.
That's where the energy
to make the 38
ATPs is coming from.
So, so far we talked a little
bit about how a
chemist views oxidation.
I touched at the beginning of
the video of how a biologist
views oxidation.
And then we saw that cellular
respiration from a chemist's
point of view is clearly showing
that the carbon is
being oxidized.
It's losing electrons.
And that the oxygen
is being reduced.
It's gaining electrons.
It's being reduced.
That electrons are going from
this carbon and they're going,
essentially, to these
oxygens right here.
Now how does the biology
definition of our
position hold up?
Well here it holds
up pretty well.
Because you can imagine, over
here, all of the hydrogens in
the equation are associated
with glucose.
And so they're either bonded,
if you look at the structure
of glucose.
The hydrogens are either bonded
to carbons or oxygens.
So these are bonded to
carbons and oxygens.
And when you go on the
right-hand side of the
equation, all of the hydrogens
are only bonding with oxygen.
So net-net, carbon definitely
lost hydrogens.
And hydrogens and oxygen
definitely gained hydrogens.
Let me write that down.
We see in respiration, carbon
lost hydrogens.
And oxygen gained hydrogens.
And that's consistent.
Because we see that by losing
hydrogens we are being
oxidized from a biologist
point of view.
And by gaining hydrogens,
oxygen is being reduced.
And just so you can kind of
makes sense of this when you
see this-- and when I start
drawing out the mechanisms,
which I will hopefully not make
too hairy-- this process
of transferring these hydrogens
is facilitated by
molecules like NAD
plus and FAD.
And we'll see that.
But really, if we just want to
reconcile the two notions, as
the hydrogens are being
transferred from one
electronegative atom to another
electronegative atom,
what's really being transferred
is the opportunity
to hog electrons.
If carbon has the hydrogen, it
gets to hog the electrons.
But if that hydrogen goes from
the carbon-- and the whole
atom; not just the nucleus, but
the whole atom goes to the
oxygen-- now the oxygen
has gained that
electron that it can hog.
And carbon has lost
the electron.
So carbon has oxidized and
oxygen has been reduced.
And I mentioned this
in previous videos.
But probably the most confusing
thing about
oxidation is that you always
want to say, all right, that
must have something
to do with oxygen.
And it does.
The word really comes
from, what would
oxygen do to something?
So oxygen, when it bonds with
things, it loses, it takes
away their electrons.
Or, in a reaction, it'll often
take away the hydrogens.
It took away the hydrogens
from the
carbon in this situation.
So that's where the term
oxidation comes from.
But you don't have to have
oxygen anywhere in your
reaction for oxidation or
reduction to occur.
Anyway, hopefully you found
that reasonably useful.
This was actually a huge pain
point for me when I learned, I
got comfortable with the
chemistry definition of
oxidation reduction.
And then all of a sudden you
open up your biology book and
they start talking about losing
and gaining hydrogens,
as opposed to electrons, and it
took me a while to really
reconcile these two notions.